pitbulls have a reputation as aggressive
and dangerous dogs because of that
they're usually overlooked at adoption
shelters and a more likely to be
euthanized
Omar Villafranca is in San Antonio Texas
he shows us the efforts to change that
stereotype and give pitbulls a worthy
new career Omar good morning good
morning these six dogs standing at
attention next to their handlers are all
pitbull mixes and all came from shelters
but next week they will head to Police
Department sheriff's departments and
correctional facilities all across the
country really focus on the boss Cora
has her eye on the ball and that's
exactly where it needs to be
she's already watching you the one and a
half year old shelter dog was rescued
from death row before giving birth to
her own litter of puppies you know this
first test is is seeing if she's okay
with confined spaces
Brad Croft runs universal canine not
supposed to work like Bab a San Antonio
based program that trains dogs to work
with law enforcement good girl he's
running drills with car okay let her go
to see if she has the chops to become a
police dog recruit how she searches for
it as a pitbull mix good girl she's an
unexpected candidate pure breeds like
German shepherds Belgian Malinois or
Labradors are traditionally chosen as
k-9 officers because of their drive to
work but Croft is taking abandoned
unadoptable pitbulls ready and teaching
them to use their powerful sense of
smell to sniff out drugs detect bombs
and track people these are the ones that
get put down you know because people
think wow that dogs got too much energy
you know and they just get looked over
and those are the dogs that work really
well for our program and they excel at
this work
the muscular pitbull has become a pariah
in recent decades reports often show
dogs identified as pitbulls as the
aggressors in horrific sometimes fatal
attacks
hundreds of cities across the country
banned the breed or require owners to
spay or neuter their dogs they've got
this breed all wrong this dog is the
exact opposite of what it's painted to
be good girl Croft hopes to change the
public perception by teaching pit bulls
to protect and serve communities
alongside their handlers so far he's
graduated more than 30 pit bulls to
police and sheriff's departments across
the country including tweeker read to me
Tweaker works in Texas with Grimes
County Sheriff Deputies Stephen siracusa
we'll find out where is looking for drug
traffickers where's it sure ku says last
dog was a yellow lab I got Tweaker I was
a little surprised but not disappointed
Tweaker if you'll notice when you go to
get her out she's ready to go she's
marking she's energetic she's kind of
pawing at the cage she wants to go to
work
in the months since she's joined the
Sheriff's Department
Tweaker has made several drug busts and
even found a weapon we're saving a life
which is a dog and then we're saving
that life to save many lives an animal
welfare group called the Animal Farm
foundation pays for the training and
boarding of these dogs now this is car
from our story this is what she'll be
doing for the rest of her working live
sniffing out drugs there she just passed
the test she'll be doing this for the
Colorado mounted Rangers with her
handler officer dawn havens
all right Omar thank you I love it they
take the dogs that are overlooked if
people want to get rid of and a lot of
people are so very very afraid of pit
bulls that's why you need to see stories
like that to show you that there is a
whole other side and the right read the
right owner and the right owner very
very important